we are joined today by dr blaine
bettinger who is an intellectual
property attorney as well
as a genealogist specializing in dna
uh producer pat and i have both taken
dna tests to try to ascertain
uh our background our ethnic background
so
dr bettinger to begin with when we take
a dna test like this and we took
the ancestry.com dna test i also did an
additional test from from 23andme
this is a saliva test how do these tests
generally speaking work what can they
tell us and what can they not tell us
so these tests are mainly used for two
different things the first
is to give us an idea a very high level
overview
of our what's called our biogeographical
ancestry or what some people call our
ethnicity
ancestry so for example a continental
level where
what percentage of our dna is european
african
asian native american and so on the
second thing we can learn from this
is we can find our genetic matches in
the database
other people who are are our genetic
relatives that have also taken these
types of tests
and when you're talking about genetic
relatives as well without giving away
any of the results yet
genetic similarities do not
necessarily correlate directly with sort
of a
a family tree match is that sort of
accurate or how can we think about that
well actually i would say in the reverse
having a genealogical match does not
mean you're going to genetically match
them
especially for more distant relatives
but if you have say
a second cousin or closer that's already
tested you'll
you will match their their dna and
you'll be able to get a rough estimate
of what your relationship is just based
on the amount
of dna you share with them all right
very good so let's start digging into
the results let's start with
david pakman show producer patrick ford
pat
give us your sense of as far as you knew
based on the stories that your family
sort of had
what did you believe before taking this
test was
going what was was your background in
terms of what these dna tests can tell
us so for my understanding of my
genetic background most of my ancestors
came to america
around the turn of the 20th century and
on my paternal side
it's mostly from the british isles
that's what i've been told
so of course england scotland wales and
ireland
and then my maternal side is split my
expectation was
evenly between lebanese and eastern
european slash polish
okay so uh dr bettinger that's pat's
understanding of his family background
let's now dig into pat's actual dna
results what can we glean from them
well first we look at i generally start
off by looking at someone's
ethnicity analysis so for example pat's
ethnicity
analysis revealed a percentage of 80
european and there was
uh around 20 west asian or middle
eastern
and so that doesn't quite break down to
the 50 50 that you might expect if the
um based on solely on what we just heard
from pat but it's
it's close um we have this this sort of
um uh great britain ireland eastern
uh eastern european breakdown of of
european
and then we also have this middle
eastern west asian uh percentage as well
now pat when you saw because when we're
we're looking at the results here
when you saw the europe east part
that does not really correlate with what
your understanding was of your
background right i mean we're seeing
great britain and we're seeing ireland
as far as the european part but europe
east did you know anything about that
i did because my maternal grandfather i
knew either came from poland or russia
and of course the border went back and
forth over the years from there
but what it was a surprise was italian
slash greek i had no understanding that
i had any of that
and i think it says what about eight or
nine percent come from that area
okay so dr bettinger this gets to sort
of my next question which is when when
we got these results there are what are
called
high confidence and low confidence
results and and
we'll see in mind that i have some very
low confidence results
what does that really mean does that
mean that there may be some sort of
coincidental dna overlap but it may not
necessarily represent
an area of someone's background or how
how valuable is that to us
that's a really good question and that's
probably one of the most common
concerns and questions about these
ethnicity estimates and
and that is that they're not a perfect
science it's it's
it's very very rough science because
what happens is you get your dna and
it's compared to these reference
populations that are obtained from these
different places
there are groups of individuals that
have been tested from great britain
eastern europe ireland
italy greece and your dna is compared to
these individuals
but if you think about it there are very
few populations today that have been in
this region
and isolated in any one region for
thousands of years or even hundreds of
years there's been lots of
intermixing especially for example all
along the the mediterranean there's been
plenty of mixing of populations there
from ireland to great britain
lots of mixing there all across central
europe and so
what happens is we it's hard to say that
if you get a say a
20 ireland for example that that's it
perfectly 20 ireland and in fact each of
these percentages have ranges
because this is analysis is run multiple
times by this company so
if you click on any of your percentages
you'll actually see a range that was
along those different
uh that that was for each of those
ethnicity predictions so for ireland
the range may be uh ten percent to
thirty percent and the average was
eighteen percent for example
all right let's now get to my results my
understanding of my family background
was
uh uh quite boring in a sense i mean as
far as i knew
i am a of ashkenazi jewish origin
i'm not aware of any blood relatives
that were anything but 100
ashkenazi jewish what would not have
surprised me from my results would have
been if there was
some uh asian dna because
in the part of europe eastern europe
where i believe my family to be from
it was not that rare to have some mixing
with asian countries but beyond that
certainly what would have been
a big surprise to me would have been you
know a
significant african origin or something
like
indian for example so dr bettinger let's
put my results up on the screen and and
we can start getting into those what are
the key points of my results
so really the the first thing that jumps
out at you is that 92
european jewish ancestry and i think
that that lines up very very well with
exactly what you were expecting to see
yeah
um yeah if if you beyond that if you
click on your
low confidence regions for example you
do see there are some very small
percentages of
other places like two percent italy
greece for example uh two percent
finland
and a few smaller percentages so those
may be instances of either there might
be some noise there
or there could be that there have been
um it's there's been
these populations that have been
introduced into your jewish ancestry at
some point
in time would it be accurate to say that
based on the results that were looked
that that we have here that that we're
looking at
that the only result that i received
with any degree of confidence
is an ashkenazi jewish background is
that fair
i think that's fair to say yes the
confidence in that is extremely
extremely high
but the others i would say i i i would i
wonder whether or not they're noise and
so
generally what i do is i only look at
the continental level i like to look at
how much european how much um african
how much native american how much asian
and that's where i get the most
confidence below that once it starts
breaking down into regions
that's where the science gets a little
bit more challenging so overall
i have a 99 european test and one
percent
africa but when you look at that one
percent in africa again it's a
one percent low confidence result
from north africa is that potentially
completely meaningless here uh
it is potentially meaningless but what i
know about that
is the fact that it is a north african
estimate and so um if you click on that
it you actually see it's africa north
which could be that
upper coast of the uh of africa
along the mediterranean there and so
again there was a lot through for
thousands of years there's been a lot of
travel across the mediterranean both
back and forth across there and so it's
possible
that at some point in in time there was
this african
um introduction of dna in your
um expert opinion as someone who's
looked at a lot of these results
uh are am i the most jewish person whose
results you've looked at i mean
it seems as though it's it's possibly
just a little bit of noise
and then an ashkenazi jewish background
as i look at it
yeah i have to say it's one of the most
uh jewish backgrounds
uh jewish estimates i've ever seen so
yes absolutely
wow so i mean i guess what we can gather
from this
is the story that i was sort of told
growing up
and based on the family tree that i've
put together it does appear to be more
or less accurate there were really no
surprises
whatsoever here but this doesn't rule
out the possibility that one of these
other minor regions at some point saw
some intermarriage
yes i think that's a that's a perfect
assessment yes wow
well i i wish my results were sort of
more interesting i mean i guess it's
interesting to confirm
it in your experience how common is it
that there are no surprises in other
words we off we heard about the white
supremacists who ended up being 14
african for example very you know that
video went viral a couple of years ago
that was a big surprise
but by and large are surprises pretty
rare on these tests
you know i i've found in my experience
that a large percentage of people
do have surprises in their in their
results primarily because if you think
about it
very few of us can build back a family
tree back a number of generations that
doesn't have holes
and so you never know what that hole
that brick wall in your tree might
represent and so i think people do find
ethnicity estimates or matches or other
things in their results that that tend
to be surprising and of course
there's a very large number of people
that find
extremely big surprises things like um
my parent was not my parent or i'm
adopted or they find
a biological family for example so those
are happening with with greater and
greater frequency
not a huge percentage but still it's
it's happening
more and more okay a couple other quick
things before
we let you go on on my test one of the
things ancestry.com will tell you
is the number and even give you specific
information about other dna matches now
when it comes to people of an ashkenazi
jewish background
you said that those dna matches can can
sort of they need to be interpreted
maybe a little differently can you talk
about that a bit
absolutely if if there's a large
percentage of jewish ancestry
then what happens is your matches appear
to be closer than they are in many cases
because there's something called
endogamy
now endogamy all it means is that there
is a higher
amount of shared dna as a result of
intermarriage within
a population for a large amount of time
so for example in in jewish culture it's
common to for this intermarriage to
occur and so as a result
we have this increased amount of dna
that's shared between
individuals from within that population
so for example if you have a predicted
uh third cousin for example then that
third cousin might actually be more
distant
genealogically genetically they share
more dna because you
uh come from this shared background very
good and then the last thing i want to
touch on and we actually can put this up
on the screen i also did a 23andme
dna test part of this was i was sort of
curious whether this entire thing is a
scam if my results would have been
drastically different between ancestry
and 23 and me there would have been some
questions to
to answer fortunately the results from
it from 23andme were very similar but on
this last image which we have that we
can put up
my uh neanderthal variants neanderthal
dna which according to the 23andme test
i have um a fewer neanderthal variants
than 59
of 23 and me test takers or customers
can you talk a little bit about what
that means
right so we're just beginning to
understand neanderthal dna
and it appears based on some recent
studies some very good studies that were
done
it appears that humans and neanderthals
modern humans and neanderthals interbred
and so as a result most non-africans
throughout the world have a
a certain amount of neanderthal dna it
appears a low amount somewhere between
uh one and five percent or so
um and it appears that intermixing
occurred in europe and so that's why for
example
africans don't seem to have that large
percentage of neanderthal dna
what's interesting is they've identified
some variants some dna
variants that appear to be to have come
from neanderthal
ancestry or neanderthal dna and so what
what 23andme does is they will look for
those variants in your dna and they'll
report them to you if you have a high
percentage and
and you're lucky i think my percentage
is actually uh much much higher so
you're less neanderthal than i am now
you said lucky
is is are there any uh objectively
positive or negative
uh sort of connotations to having more
or less neanderthal dna
not that we're aware of however the fact
that there's this consistent
low level amount of neanderthal dna in
our
in our genomes suggests that it was
beneficial to us in some way
that we maintained that low level
because it provided us with some
advantage and
that's that science is still out there
i've seen a couple of papers that have
talked about that and i expect there to
be a lot of interesting developments in
that area in the future
and for people who are interested in in
reading more about that
um in yuval harare's not his most recent
book
homo deus but the previous one sapiens
he actually writes
somewhat extensively about what we're
now learning about
intermixing between neanderthal and homo
sapiens
dr blaine bettinger absolutely
fascinating i
can't thank you enough for for coming on
and talking to us about this today pat
any other questions you have for the
doctor um
so i noticed three percent from the
caucus mountains and one percent
indian in my results um that certainly
threw me as a surprise i didn't have any
uh
expectations of that in your experience
do you think that makes sense do you
think that jives with my results
uh caucasus definitely does because
that's in the right region
um however the iberia the iberian
peninsula for example those are all
pretty low levels anything i generally
say around
1 or less i i generally will be
concerned that it's just
noise above that it appears to be a
generally pretty accurate um
estimate as far as you know the the
general
caveats about ethnicity estimates go all
right
dr bettinger thanks again for being on
really really appreciate it
thank you very much